Buonasera
Grazie
Noi siamo sempre qua invece
Non ci muoviamo
Allora
Siamo a Tokyo
Nell'estate del 1935
Fate mente locale
Siamo fra le due guerre
Ma la prima si sta già allontanando
Nel tempo
E la seconda invece è già molto vicina
Il mondo sta già precipitando
Verso la seconda guerra mondiale
Siamo a Tokyo nell'estate del 1935
In Italia
C'è Mussolini
Al culmine della sua popolarità
In Germania c'è Hitler
In Unione Sovietica c'è Stalin
Negli Stati Uniti c'è Roosevelt
E si sta cominciando a intravedere
La fine della grande crisi
In Giappone succedono cose
Che agli occhi degli occidentali sono molto strane
Un giorno di luglio
Del 1935
Un certo tenente colonnello
Aizawa
Arriva a Tokyo
In treno
Dalla cittadina dove si trova in guarnigione
Va al ministero della guerra
Cerca l'ufficio
Di un funzionario del ministero
Il generale Nagata
Entra nell'ufficio
Tira fuori la sciabola
E ammazza il generale Nagata
Al processo il tenente colonnello Aizawa
Dirà che si vergogna di una cosa sola
Di non essere riuscito a ucciderlo
Con un solo colpo di spada
Come dovrebbe fare un samurai ben addestrato
Al processo emerge che questo omicidio
Al ministero della guerra giapponese
Non è una questione privata
Ma ha a che fare con un conflitto
Che sta spaccando l'esercito giapponese
C'è un conflitto tra i vecchi generali
Al potere
Moderati
Legati ai grandi trust industriali
E finanziari giapponesi
E tutta una generazione di giovani ufficiali
Spesso di origine contadina
O comunque modesta
Estremisti
Con forti simpatie fasciste
In Giappone c'è una tradizione
Di conflitti di questo genere
C'è un termine in giapponese
Che risale al quindicesimo secolo
Il Gekoku Jō
Che vuol dire
Il rovesciamento degli anziani
Da parte dei giovani
In Giappone sta succedendo questo
I giovani fremono
E vogliono prendere il potere
Il processo del tenente colonnello Aizawa
Per omicidio
Dura molti mesi
Durante questo processo
Un bel giorno
Nel febbraio del 36
Un gruppo di giovani ufficiali
Fa uscire i soldati dalle caserme
Occupa il ministero della guerra
Il Parlamento
La sede della polizia
Attacca le case del primo ministro
E di una serie di ministri
Due ministri vengono ammazzati in casa loro
Il presidente del consiglio
Si salva solo perché i giovani ufficiali
Che gli rompono in casa sua
Trovano suo cognato
Lo scambiano per il padrone di casa
E lo ammazzano
Dopodiché
I giovani ufficiali ribelli
Dichiarano
Che loro sono scesi in campo
Per senso del dovere
Nei confronti dell'imperatore
E non fanno nient'altro
Come se si aspettassero
Che l'imperatore Hirohito
Intervenga in loro favore
Il governo per due giorni
Negozia con i ribelli
Come se li riconoscesse come un interlocutore
Nel frattempo fa circondare
Tutti gli edifici occupati dai militari ribelli
Li fa circondare soprattutto da truppe della marina
Tutti sanno che in Giappone
La marina e l'esercito
Si odiano
Dopo tre giorni i ribelli si arrendono
La maggior parte vengono processati
Condannati a morte
E giustiziati
I governi occidentali
Fanno molta
Ecco io adesso non mi fermo a chiedervi
Quanto vi è chiaro cosa stava succedendo in Giappone
In quel momento
Ai governi occidentali
Non è chiaro per niente
Nessuno ci capisce niente
Il Giappone è un paese lontano
Complicato
Nessuno conosce la lingua
È un paese impenetrabile
Che comunica poco all'esterno
E non ci sono specialisti
In occidente
O pochissimi
Che conoscono le dinamiche interne
Di questa società in crisi
Anche i giornalisti europei a Tokyo
Che già sono pochi
Brancolano nel buio
C'è un solo giornalista
Che è capace di spiegare cosa succede
È un giornalista tedesco
Accreditato a Tokyo
Da un paio d'anni
Membro del partito nazista
In ottimi rapporti con la sua ambasciata
E che ha una conoscenza stranamente approfondita
Della politica giapponese
Questo giornalista dopo l'insurrezione dei giovani ufficiali
Pubblica in Germania
Un grosso
Manda in Germania da Tokyo
Un grosso articolo
In cui spiega in modo efficace
Queste dinamiche
Complicate
Questa lotta di classe e di generazione
All'interno dell'esercito
L'articolo ha un grande successo
Viene riprodotto in tutto il mondo
Perfino la Pravda a Mosca
Lo traduce in russo
Al giornalista
Gli amici fanno i complimenti
Sei diventato veramente famoso
In tutto il mondo
Sei l'esperto di Giappone
Perfino per quei comunisti a Mosca
Il giornalista ride
Ma in cuor suo
E furibondo
Quella sera va a trovare
Un altro tedesco
Un industriale
Un piccolo industriale tedesco
Stabilito a Tokyo
Che abita in un sobborgo di Tokyo
L'industriale in casa
Tiene nascosta una radio ricetrasmittente
Che è in grado di trasmettere fino in Siberia
Da dove la trasmissione viene poi raccolta
E rimandata a Mosca
Il giornalista chiama Mosca
E dice
Ma non sarete mica impazziti
Che pubblicate i miei articoli
Sulla Pravda
Che non succeda più
Perché nessuno deve immaginare
Che c'è un qualche collegamento
Fra me e l'Unione Sovietica
Il giornalista si chiamava Richard Sorge
Era iscritto al partito comunista dal 1918
Ed era a capo di una rete di spie
Piazzata a Tokyo
Dal servizio informazioni dell'armata rossa
Una rete di spie
Che probabilmente fra tanti gruppi di spie
Che hanno operato
Durante la seconda
Prima e durante la seconda guerra mondiale
E forse quella che ha influenzato
Più direttamente
L'esito della seconda guerra mondiale
Ed è
Del dottor Sorge
E della sua rete di spie
Che io proverò a raccontarvi questa sera
Richard Sorge era figlio
Di un ingegnere tedesco
E di una madre russa
Al liceo a Berlino
Era il primo della classe
In tutte le materie
Uno di quelli che i compagni
Come dire in genere
Non stanno proprio simpaticissimi
I compagni al liceo
L'avevano soprannominato
Il primo ministro
Però
Però come tutti i giovani studenti tedeschi
Della sua generazione
Nati alla fine dell'ottocento
Era un bravo patriota tedesco
E allo scoppio
Della prima guerra mondiale
Si era ruolato volontario
E si era fatto
Quattro anni di guerra al fronte
Era stato ferito
Tre volte
Alle gambe
Alla fine molto gravemente
Per cui è rimasto leggermente zoppo
Per tutta la vita
E come dire
E come tanti altri
Durante la guerra
Richard Sorge era cambiato
Aveva incontrato gente
Che prima
Un ragazzo borghese
Come lui
Non avrebbe mai incontrato
Pacifisti
Socialdemocratici
Comunisti
Ed era diventato comunista
Anche lui
Forse il fatto che aveva perso
Due fratelli in guerra
Un pochino anche
Avrà contato
Nell'orientarlo
In una certa direzione
Fatto sta che subito dopo
La fine della guerra
Richard Sorge
Ventenne
Si iscrive
Al partito comunista
L'anno dopo
Si laurea
In scienze politiche
Ed ora in poi
Sarà il dottor Sorge
A questo punto
È già schedato
Dalla polizia tedesca
Come agitatore comunista
Sottolineo questo aspetto
Perché
Come vedremo fra poco
Dieci anni dopo
Alla polizia tedesca
Nessuno si ricordava più di lui
La polizia
I tedeschi non sono sempre
Così efficienti
Come a volte ci immaginiamo
E questo è un caso
Proprio clamoroso
Da questo punto di vista
Si erano persi la schedatura
Perché nel 1920
Lo sapevano benissimo
Che questo giovane
Dottor Sorge
Era un comunista
Dunque i tedeschi
Se lo dimenticano
I sovietici
Invece lo notano
E a un certo punto
Lui parla anche russo
C'ha la mamma russa
E a un certo punto
Quindi lo invitano a Mosca
A lavorare
Per il Comintern
Per l'organizzazione
Che coordina
Tutti i partiti comunisti
Del mondo
Accetta
Nel 1925
Il dottor Sorge
A 29 anni
Lascia la Germania
E si stabilisce
A Mosca
All'inizio alloggia
Al famoso hotel Lux
L'hotel riservato
Ai comunisti stranieri
Dove alloggiava
Anche togliati
Dove alloggiavano
Tanti che poi
Hanno fatto una brutta fine
In quello stesso anno
Prende la cittadinanza
Sovietica
La tessera
Del partito comunista
Sovietico
Si è portato dietro
La moglie
Cristiane
Una moglie tedesca
Che era la moglie
Di uno dei suoi professori
All'università
E ha piantato il marito
Per mettersi con lui
Se la porta dietro
In unione sovietica
Però poi
Le cose non vanno tanto bene
A Cristiane non piace
Insomma
Un bel momento
Lei lo pianta
E torna in Germania
Esce dalla nostra storia
Cristiane
Ma io l'ho voluta citare
Perché lei ha lasciato
Un commento
Su Richard Sorge
Che è molto istruttivo
A Cristiane
Tanti anni dopo
Hanno poi chiesto
Di questa sua storia
Con lo studente
Di suo marito
E lui
Che la sedotta
E Cristiane dice
Lei lo chiama
Col diminutivo
Richard
Da bambino
Quando imparava
A parlare
Faceva fatica
A pronunciare
Il suo nome
Anziché dire
Richard
Diceva
Icca
Ed allora
In famiglia
L'hanno sempre chiamato
Icca
Cristiane dice
Non mi ha mica
Sedotto lui
No no
Sono io
Che mi sono innamorata
Icca
Non aveva bisogno
Di fare la corte
A nessuno
Tutti accorrevano
Intorno a lui
Uomini
E donne
Allora
Negli anni venti
L'uomo che piaceva
A tutti
E che affascinava
Viene mandato
Più volte
In missione
All'estero
Per conto
Del Comintern
Fra i portuali
In Scandinavia
Fra i minatori
In Inghilterra
E poi nel
Il suo destino
Cambia
E' convocato
Nell'ufficio
Del generale
Jan Karlovich
Berzin
Comandante
Della quarta
Sezione
Del servizio
Segreto
Dell'armata
Rossa
La sezione
Che si occupa
Di creare
Reti di agenti
All'estero
Il generale
Berzin
Propone
Al dottor
Sorge
Di andare
A impiantare
Una rete
Di spie
In Cina
A Shanghai
La Cina
E' un paese
In ebollizione
In teoria
Comanda
Chiang Kai-shek
Ma in realtà
Gran parte
Del paese
E' in mano
Ai signori
Della guerra
C'è un fortissimo
Movimento comunista
Clandestino
E ci sono
I giapponesi
Ai confini
Che aspettano
Solo l'occasione
Per cominciare
L'invasione
Della Cina
Mosca
Avrebbe un gran
Bisogno
Di informazioni
Sulla Cina
Ma non ha
Nessun modo
Legale
Di averle
Non c'è
Nemmeno
Un consolato
Sovietico
In Cina
E Chiang Kai-shek
Ammazza
Tutti i comunisti
Su cui riesce
A mettere
Le mani
Il generale
Berzin
Propone
A Sorge
Di andare
Lì
In un paese
Del genere
A vedere
Se è possibile
Mettere in piedi
Una rete
Di spie comuniste
Dottor Sorge
Accetta
Va in Cina
Presentandosi
Come giornalista
Che intende
Fare dei reportage
E li fa
Effettivamente
Si sistema
A Shanghai
Io qui
Non la faccio
Lunga
Quando preparavo
Questa lezione
Mi son detto
Di Shanghai
Gli parlerò
Per dieci minuti
Perché è troppo
Affascinante
Invece no
Neanche un minuto
Perché non ho tempo
Ma
Immaginate
Questa città
Che è sotto
Sovranità cinese
In teoria
Ma in realtà
Mezza Shanghai
Sono concessioni
Occidentali
Governate
E con poliziotti
Dei paesi occidentali
In particolare
C'è una grossa
Concessione francese
Dove comanda
La polizia francese
E in più
Ci sono i giapponesi
Subito fuori
Che minacciano
Continuamente
Di scatenare
L'invasione
I comunisti
Clandestini
Ricchi
Industriali
E finanzieri
Occidentali
Insomma
Un mondo pazzesco
Ristoranti
Occidentali
Librerie
Tedesche
In questo mondo
Il dottor Sorge
Rimane per tre anni
Manda in Germania
Meravigliosi articoli
Di analisi
Della situazione
Cinese
Facendosi un nome
Come grande esperto
Di Medio Oriente
Manda a Mosca
Un'enorme quantità
Di informazioni
Torna a Mosca
Nel 1932
Lo accolgono
Con grandi strette
Di mano
E gli chiedono
Se è pronto
A ripartire
Per un'altra missione
Il dottor Sorge
Dice
Che prima
Vorrebbe finire
Il libro
Che ha cominciato
A scrivere
Sull'agricoltura
Cinese
Perché lui
E' uno
Che si interessa
Delle cose
E' all'anima
Dello studioso
In realtà
E' laureato
In scienze politiche
E' un economista
Quando sta in un paese
Comincia a studiare
Sta scrivendo un libro
Sull'agricoltura cinese
Che per piacere
Lo lasciano in pace
Finchè non l'ha finito
Il generale
Jan Karlovic
Berzin
Gli dice
Va bene
Se proprio
Devi finire il libro
Eh
Quanto pensi di me
Non so
Fatto sta
Che dopo due mesi
Lo richiamano
E gli dicono
Finito il libro
Il libro
Non è finito
Ma il servizio segreto
Dell'armata rossa
Avrebbe una gran voglia
Di rimandare in giro
Il dottor Sorge
E gli dicono
Dove ti mandiamo
La prossima volta
Sorge scherzando
Dice
Ma sono stato in Cina
Potrei andare in Giappone
Mentre ero lì a Shanghai
Ho fatto un viaggetto
A Tokyo
Mi è piaciuto
Interessante quel paese
Potrei tornare lì
Se proprio ci tenete
Ma lui scherzava
Qualche giorno dopo
Il generale Berzing
Lo richiama
E gli dice
Che ha raccontato
La sua battuta
Al comitato centrale
Del partito comunista
Sovietico
Dove l'hanno presa
Molto sul serio
Avrebbero un gran bisogno
Di agenti a Tokyo
Oh
Tenete conto
Di che paese
È il Giappone
In quel momento
Al di là del fatto
Che come vi ho già detto
È un paese
Poco trasparente
Anzi
Impenetrabile
Per gli occidentali
È un paese
In quel momento
Xenofobo
Apertamente
Dove c'è
Un'ossessione
Maniacale
Delle spie
Dove ogni
Occidante
Ogni straniero
È seguito
Dalla polizia
Anche da più
Di una polizia
Ci sono diverse
Polizie segrete
C'è il
Kempeitai
La polizia segreta
Dell'esercito
C'è la
Tocco
Che è l'equivalente
Della Gestapo
La polizia segreta
Ed è un paese
Ferocemente
Anticomunista
Ed è un paese
Che confina
Con l'Unione Sovietica
Perché non dimentichiamoci
Facciamo un rapido
Raccordo temporale
Ricordate la guerra
Russo-Giapponese
Sembra un'altra epoca
Ma non erano passati
Neanche 30 anni
La guerra russo-Giapponese
Era cosa di ieri
E i giapponesi
Erano impiantati
Saldamente
In Corea
In Manciuria
E confinavano
Con l'Unione Sovietica
In Manciuria
C'era un poderoso
Esercito giapponese
L'armata
Del Quantung
Che si comportava
Quasi come una potenza
Indipendente
Faceva la sua politica
Nei confronti
Della Cina
Della Unione Sovietica
Obbediva
Astento
Agli ordini
Del governo giapponese
Avete capito
Che è un momento
In cui
Quando i generali
Si stufano
Del primo ministro
In Giappone
Lo fanno ammazzare
E quindi
A Mosca
Hanno un gran bisogno
Di sapere
Cosa intende fare
Il Giappone
E non lo capisce nessuno
Hanno un gran bisogno
Di sapere
Quali sono
Gli umori
Dell'armata
Del Quantung
Se il confine
Della Mongolia
E della Manciuria
È in pericolo
Oppure no
E in Giappone
L'Unione Sovietica
Non ha neanche
Un agente
Non si sa neanche
Se è possibile
Averne
Non si sa
Se è possibile
Che un radiotrasmittente
Comunichi
Tra il Giappone
E l'Unione Sovietica
Non ci ha mai provato
Non si sa
Se è possibile
Reclutare
Dei comunisti
Giapponesi
E convincerli
A lavorare
Per noi
Non si sa niente
Al Dottor Sorge
Dicono
Guarda
Ci sarebbe da fare
Questo esperimento
Se ti va
Vai lì
Stai lì
Un paio d'anni
Con calma
E vedi
Se la cosa
Si può fare
Icca
Dice che la cosa
Gli interessa molto
Lo stuzzica l'idea
Ci andrà
E dunque
Bisogna mandare
Il Dottor Sorge
Da Mosca
A Tokyo
In un paese
Ferocemente
Anticomunista
Che non ha relazioni
Con l'Unione Sovietica
Sorge
È uno
Che ha un principio
Molto chiaro
Meno bugie
Dici
Più è difficile
Che ti scoprano
Se è possibile
Non ne devi proprio
Dire di bugie
Di conseguenza
Lui andrà
A Tokyo
Nella persona
Del Dottor
Richard Sorge
Giornalista
Esperto
Di Estremo Oriente
C'è solo
Il piccolo dettaglio
Che non ci può andare
Venendo dalla Russia
Ovviamente
Perciò torna a Berlino
E il maggio 1933
Notate le date
Hitler è al potere
Da pochi mesi
Però le relazioni
Con l'Unione Sovietica
Ci sono ancora
Sono due paesi
Come dire
Considerati
I paria
Della comunità internazionale
La Germania
E l'Unione Sovietica
Quindi hanno rapporti
In quel momento
Sorge può tornare a Berlino
E arrivato a Berlino
Chiede il passaporto
Per il Giappone
Ed essendo già abituato
A scrivere articoli
Di giornale
Sull'Oriente
Fa il giro
Dei giornali tedeschi
Chiedendo
Se sono interessati
Ai suoi reportage
Da Tokyo
E trova diversi giornali
Che sono interessati
Fa anche un'altra cosa
In Germania
Viveva a quell'epoca
Un personaggio curioso
E molto famoso
All'epoca
Il professor
Karl Haushofer
Era uno studioso
Di geopolitica
E di strategia
Di fama mondiale
Una specie di Lutwack
Per capirci
Celeberrimo
Era anche un militare
Che nella prima guerra mondiale
Era arrivato al grado
Di generale
Cosa che Lutwack
Amerebbe molto
Ma non credo
Che l'abbiano mai fatto generale
Ma invece
Haushofer
Sì
E questo in Germania
Serve
È un personaggio
Rispettatissimo
Ed è un esperto
Di Giappone
Prima della prima
Guerra mondiale
Il dottor Haushofer
Era stato in Giappone
Come istruttore
Dell'esercito tedesco
E lui sostiene
Che se la Germania
Ha perso la guerra
La prima
È per l'ignoranza
Dei tedeschi
La loro ignoranza
Della situazione
Geopolitica mondiale
Nella prima guerra mondiale
La Germania
E il Giappone
Erano nemici
Il professor Haushofer
Teorizza
Che la prossima volta
Germania e Giappone
Devono mettersi insieme
Solo così
Ce la possono fare
Ma queste
Non sono solo
Le teorie
Di un accademico
Perché il caso
Vuole che il professor
Haushofer
Sia un amico
Intimo
Di Rudolf Hess
Il braccio destro
Di Hitler
E quindi
È in grado
Di influenzare
Concretamente
La politica
Della Germania
Nazista
Ecco
Anche sul professor
Haushofer
Si potrebbe fare
Una lezione intera
E io adesso comunque
Una piccola digressione
La farò
Perché è un personaggio
Troppo affascinante
Avete un po' capito
Il tipo
Un patriota tedesco
Puro e duro
Che sogna
La rivincita
Un piccolo problema
Del professor Haushofer
È che sua moglie
Era mezzo ebrea
E però
Essendo amico
Intimo
Di Rudolf Hess
Può ottenere
Per la moglie
E per i figli
Un certificato
Di arianità
Che li mette
Al sicuro
Quasi al sicuro
Perché
Vado un po' avanti
Ma la storia
È tragica
Ma appassionante
Qualche anno dopo
Nel 44
Uno dei figli
Del professor Haushofer
Giovane ufficiale
Sarà coinvolto
Nell'attentato
Del 20 luglio
Contro Hitler
E fucilato
E nel 45
Dopo la sconfitta
Della Germania
Il professor Haushofer
E la sua moglie
Mezza ebrea
Si suicideranno
Avvelenandosi
Con l'arsenico
Ma siamo ancora
Molto lontani
Mancano ancora
11 anni
Siamo ancora
Nel 33
E il giovane
E brillante giornalista
Il dottor Sorge
Va a Monaco
A trovare
L'illustre
Professor Haushofer
Gli spiega
Che lui sta andando
A Tokyo
E gli chiede
Se è interessato
È certo che è interessato
E se può dargli
Delle lettere di presentazione
È certo che può dargliele
Il professor Haushofer
Conosce tutti
Per cui
Sorge partirà
Da Berlino
Con lettere di presentazione
Di questo grande
Intellettuale nazista
Per l'ambasciatore
Tedesco
A Tokyo
Ma non solo
Siccome il viaggio
Oggi si va in Giappone
Con l'aereo
Ci metti un po' di tempo
Ma ci vai
All'epoca
Devi andare per nave
In America
Poi da lì
Ecco insomma
Il viaggio
Porterà Sorge
Negli Stati Uniti
Si fermerà lì
Per un po'
Allora il professor Haushofer
Gli chiede
Ti interessa
Una lettera di presentazione
Per l'ambasciatore
Giapponese
A Washington
E' certo che mi interessa
Quindi Sorge
Spia sovietica
Parte da Berlino
Munito di lettere
Di presentazione
Di illustri
Personalità naziste
Per tutte le destinazioni
Che gli possono interessare
Il fatto del passaporto
Lo preoccupava
Un po' di più
Perché si tratta comunque
Di andare alla polizia
E come vi dicevo
La polizia
Dieci anni prima
Sapeva benissimo
Chi era
Richard Sorge
Schedato
Come comunista
Sorge decide
Di rischiare
Va alla polizia
Di Berlino
Alla polizia
Non sanno chi sia
Gli danno il passaporto
Senza fare nessun problema
Il regime
Si è appena installato
La Gestapo
E' ancora in rodaggio
Evidentemente
Non hanno ancora
Tanto affinato i sistemi
Perciò gli danno
Il passaporto
Per il Giappone
Il come dire
Il giovane agitatore
Comunista
Non esiste più
Sotto lo stesso nome
Adesso c'è un famoso
Giornalista tedesco
Che parte per Tokyo
E già che c'è
Prima di partire
Fa domanda di iscrizione
Al partito nazista
E' talmente sicuro di sé
Che quando arriva a Tokyo
Manda il suo primo messaggio
A Mosca
In cui dice
Credo di riuscire
A menarli tutti
Per il naso
E infatti ci riesce
E nessuno
E' menato
Per il naso
Così completamente
Come l'ambasciata tedesca
Dovete immaginare
La situazione
Siamo nel 33
Noi siamo abituati
A pensare
All'alleanza
Tra Germania e Giappone
Il patto d'acciaio
Poi ci siamo entrati
Anche noi
Che Dio ci perdoni
Il patto
Roma-Berlino-Tokio
Ecco
Nel 33
Non c'è ancora
Niente del genere
Per i giapponesi
La Germania
E' un qualunque
Paese
Europeo
Ostile
Sono stati nemici
Nella prima guerra mondiale
Voi immaginate
I diplomatici tedeschi
A Tokyo
Che vivono
In questo paese
Che capiscono poco
Anche loro
E siamo nel 33
In Germania
E' appena andato
Al potere Hitler
Il partito nazista
I diplomatici tedeschi
Di carriera
Non sono tutti nazisti
Anzi
Sono lì a Tokyo
Che cercano di capire
Cosa sta succedendo
A casa
E gli arriva
Piovuto dal cielo
Questo dono del cielo
Per l'appunto
Questo compatriota
Simpaticissimo
Molto ben introdotto
Ben informato
Che arriva lì
Racconta tutto
E sa anche
Molte cose del Giappone
Molte più di quelle
Che sanno i diplomatici tedeschi
Distanza lì
Lo adorano
Gli chiedono
Se ha bisogno di aiuto
Vanno loro
A chiederglielo
Come diceva Cristiane
Sua moglie
Icca
Non ha bisogno
Di chiedere niente
Vanno tutti da lui
Gli dicono
Vuoi delle lettere
Di presentazione
Per il governo giapponese
Ce le ho già
Dice Sorge
E come mai le hai
A Washington
Sono andato
All'ambasciata giapponese
E mi hanno dato
Delle lettere di presentazione
All'ambasciata tedesca
Spalancano gli occhi
Questo è un uomo meraviglioso
Bisogna tenerselo caro
E' anche un uomo fortunato
Il dottor Sorge
Una delle persone
Per cui in Germania
Gli hanno dato
Delle lettere
E' un certo
Colonnello
Ott
Il colonnello
E' un istruttore
Presso l'esercito
Giapponese
Un tedesco
Sorge va a trovarlo
Anche qui
Provate a immaginare
Il colonnello Ott
E la moglie
Vivono
In una città
Di provincia
Giapponese
Dove non conoscono
Nessuno
E sono tenuti
A distanza
Arriva
Questo compatriota
Da Berlino
Allegro
Famoso
Ricco
Oltretutto
Simpaticissimo
Diventano subito
Amiconi
Non è stato mai
Chiarito neanche
Il processo
Se ci sia anche
Una storia
Fra il dottor Sorge
E la moglie
Del colonnello Ott
Questa è una cosa
Che è rimasta
A livello di pettegolezzo
Ma certamente
Loro diventano amicissimi
Giocano a scacchi
Sono tutti e due
Ex combattenti
Nasce una solida
Amicizia
E perché vi dicevo
Che il dottor Sorge
E' fortunato
Sei mesi dopo
Il colonnello Ott
Viene promosso
E trasferito
A Tokyo
All'ambasciata
Come ha detto
Militare dell'ambasciata
Qualche anno dopo
L'ambasciatore tedesco
A Tokyo
Viene trasferito
A Berlino
Alla Wilhelmstrasse
Al ministero degli esteri
Non hanno nessun esperto
Di Giappone
Devono sostituire
L'ambasciatore
Promuovono
Il colonnello Ott
Che quindi diventa
Ambasciatore tedesco
A Tokyo
E il suo più grande
E fedele amico
E' il dottor Sorge
Di conseguenza
Negli anni
Capite
Sono gli anni
In cui la Germania
E il Giappone
Firmano il patto d'acciaio
In quegli anni
Sorge
E' amico intimo
Dell'ambasciatore tedesco
Va e viene
All'ambasciata
Come se fosse
A casa sua
Quando il colonnello Ott
Deve
Come dire
Mettere in cifrario
Segreto
Un dispaccio
Particolarmente
Complesso
Si fa aiutare
Dal suo amico
Il dottor Sorge
Quando deve
Mandare un rapporto
A Berlino
Gli chiede
Se gli da una mano
A scriverlo
Quando riceve
Documenti riservati
Gli dice
Vuoi dare un'occhiata
Anche tu
Certo
E il dottor Sorge
A volte gli dice
Guarda questo è
Veramente interessante
Posso portarlo
A casa
Certo
E a casa
Sorge
Fotografa
A un certo punto
L'ambasciatore Ott
Chiede al suo amico
Il dottor Sorge
Ma e se ti nominassi
Capo ufficio stampa
Dell'ambasciata
E l'unica volta
In cui Sorge
Si comporta
In modo un po' strano
Perché sa benissimo
Che assumere
Un ruolo ufficiale
All'ambasciata
Bisognerà comunicarlo
Al ministero
A Berlino
E magari
Stavolta
Al ministero
A Berlino
Vanno di nuovo
Un po' a frugare
Nel suo passato
Questa cosa
Non gli piace
Quindi dice
All'ambasciatore Ott
Che lui non ha voglia
Di assumere
Incarichi ufficiali
Però continuerà
A aiutarlo
Con i dispacci segreti
Come prima
Assolutamente
Ott ci rimane
Un po' male
Poi però
Se ne fa una ragione
Insomma
Morale
Una delle principali
Fonti di informazione
In tutti quegli anni
Della spia sovietica
Richard Sorge
È l'ambasciata
Sovietica
Tedesca
Dove lui
È a casa sua
E vede tutto
Sta molto simpatico
Ai diplomatici
Dell'ambasciata
Anche perché
Dal punto di vista
Politico
È di una straordinaria
Abilità
Abbiamo detto
Che ha fatto domande
Di iscrizione
Al partito nazista
E infatti
Regolarmente
Gli arriva a Tokyo
La tessera
Ah su questo
C'è una cosa fantastica
Che dimostra
Che roba era
Il partito nazista
A Berlino
In archivio
Hanno trovato
La scheda di iscrizione
Di Richard Sorge
Al partito nazista
Nella sezione
Dei residenti
All'estero
Tutto quello
Che c'è scritto
È
Nome
Richard Sorge
Residenza
Tokyo
Cina
Poi
A matita
Qualcuno
Ha tirato un frego
Su Cina
E ha messo
Giappone
Questo è tutto
Quello
Che il partito nazista
Sa del suo nuovo
Iscritto
Ma a Tokyo
Il dottor Sorge
Che è un uomo
Molto abile
Che ha capito
Che questi diplomatici
Tedeschi
Non sono nazisti
Fanatici
E lui fa il nazista
Però spiritoso
Però critico
Che fa anche
Le battute
Con cui si può
Discorrere liberamente
E ai diplomatici
Tedeschi
Piace da morire
A un certo punto
La sezione
Nazista
Di Tokyo
Vorrebbe nominare
Sorge
Direttore della sezione
Lui ne parla
All'ambasciatore Ott
E l'ambasciatore Ott
E scherzando
Gli dice
Beh
Ogni tanto
Un führer di buonsenso
Servirebbe nel partito
Dopodiché
Lui però
Rifiuta la carica
Perché appunto
Preferisce
E poi c'è la rete
C'è la rete
Degli agenti
Giapponesi
E qui bisogna
Capirci
Perché Sorge
Ha bisogno
Di agenti
Giapponesi
Quello che noi
Chiamiamo spionaggio
Anche oggi
Consiste
In gran parte
Non nel
Carpire
Documenti
Segreti
Violando
Casseforti
E codici
L'attività
Dello spionaggio
Anche oggi
Consiste
In parte
In grossa parte
Nel lavorare
Su quelle che loro
In gergo
Chiamano le fonti
Aperte
Il che vuol dire
I giornali pubblicano
Un sacco di roba
I giornali
Le riviste specializzate
I rapporti
Delle aziende
Tutta roba pubblica
Ma è un enorme lavoro
Leggersi tutto
Paragonare
Confrontare
Verificare
Estendere
Dei rapporti
Qualunque rete
Di informatori
Deve farlo
In Giappone
Negli anni
Trenta
Anche solo
Fare questo lavoro
Sulle cosiddette
Fonti aperte
Non è per niente
Facile
Intanto
Nessuno sa bene
Il giapponese
Neanche Sorge
Lo sa bene
Un po'
Lo impara
Ma
Ma non solo
Il Giappone
Come vi dicevo
È un paese
Ossessionato
Dalle spie
Dove gli stranieri
Sono seguiti
E spiati loro
Appunto
E dove
Ai giornalai
E ai librai
È vietato
Vendere agli stranieri
Libri o riviste
Che parlino
Dei problemi interni
Del Giappone
E anzi
Se uno straniero
Viene a interessarsi
Di queste pubblicazioni
È dovere
Del libraio
Denunciarlo
Alla polizia
Ne consegue
Che anche soltanto
Raccogliere
Quelle informazioni
Che per i giapponesi
Sono di libero accesso
Per uno straniero
È difficile
Quindi ci vogliono
Dei giapponesi
Ed è in questo senso
Che intorno a Sorge
Nasce
Una vera e propria rete
Primo
Sorge era stato
A Shanghai
Per tre anni
E a Shanghai
Aveva conosciuto
Dei giapponesi
Alcuni di questi
Giapponesi
Erano dei comunisti
Con cui Sorge
Sotto falso nome
Aveva preso contatto
E verificato
Che sarebbero stati
Disponibili
A lavorare
Per il comunismo
Riprende contatto
Con loro
C'è tutta una parte
Di cui volevo parlare
Ma anche di quella
Non parlerò
Perché la storia
È troppo lunga
Delle tecniche
Da romanzo
Per cui
Si fa sapere
A una certa persona
Che quel certo giorno
Dovrà trovarsi
Al parco di Nara
Portando una cravatta verde
Quando vedrà
Un altro giapponese
Che porta una cravatta
Marrone
E che ha
In una tasca destra
Una coppia
Del giornale
Dovrà dirgli
Bel tempo
Oggi
Vero
Allora
Ci siamo capiti
In questo modo
Sorge
Ricontatta
Persone che aveva
Conosciuto in precedenza
Ve ne cito solo una
Perché è il più importante
Diventa un po'
L'alter ego
Di Sorge
E anche al processo
Avrà un grande ruolo
È un giornalista
Famoso
Lavora per il maggior
Giornale giapponese
La Zai Shimbun
Si chiama
Ozaki
Ed è anche lui
Un esperto di Cina
È molto legato
Al mondo politico
Giapponese
Conosce
Ministri
E primi ministri
A un certo punto
Viene nominato
Ufficialmente
Consulente
Del governo
Giapponese
Per i problemi
Cinesi
Ozaki
Hotsumi
A un certo punto
Viene nominato
Ecco
Vi parlavo prima
Dell'armata del
Quantung
L'armata giapponese
In Manciuria
Che si comporta
Quasi come una potenza
Indipendente
E che è la principale
Minaccia sui confini
Dell'Unione Sovietica
L'armata del
Quantung
Ovviamente
Ha dei rapporti
Molto stretti
Con dei trust
Finanziari
E industriali
Il principale
Di questi
Si chiama
Le ferrovie
Della Manciuria
Meridionale
Ozaki
A un certo punto
Viene nominato
Capo ufficio stampa
Delle ferrovie
Della Manciuria
Meridionale
Il che vuol dire
Essere a stretto
Contatto
Con i processi
Decisionali
Dell'armata
Del Quantung
E Ozaki
In segreto
Uomo noto
Conosciuto
Rispettato
Famoso
In Giappone
In segreto
E comunista
E quando lo hanno contattato
Ha confermato
Che lui
E' disposto
A lavorare
Per il Comintern
E a fornire informazioni
Altri giapponesi
Comunisti
Vengono scovati
In quel mondo
Interessante
Che è il mondo
Degli emigrati
Giapponesi
Negli Stati Uniti
In California
C'è una numerosa
Comunità
Di emigrati
Giapponesi
Sapete che
Negli anni
20 e 30
Il partito
Comunista
Negli Stati Uniti
E' abbastanza presente
E verrà poi
Spazzato via
Dalla guerra
E dal
Maccartismo
Soprattutto
Ma negli anni
20 e 30
C'è
Per cui
Molti giapponesi
Emigrati
Negli Stati Uniti
Sono diventati
Comunisti
Gli agenti
Segreti
Di Mosca
Li vanno a cercare
Li contattano
E gli chiedono
Se sono disposti
A lavorare
E più di uno
E' disposto
A lavorare
E a quel punto
Lo rimandano
In Giappone
E lo mettono
In contatto
Col dottor Sorge
Avrà moltissimi
Agenti
Alla fine
Tutti lo fanno
Per pura
Convinzione
Ideale
Perché soldi
Ce ne è pochissimi
E rischi enormi
Fino alla fine
Nessuno di loro
Lo tradirà
Ora
La cosa straordinaria
E' che a questo punto
Noi abbiamo
Questo personaggio
Che vive totalmente
Alla luce del sole
E che in realtà
Non viola
Quasi nessuna legge
Giapponese
Certo
Quando fotocopia
Di nascosto
I documenti segreti
Dell'ambasciata tedesca
Ai tedeschi
Questo potrebbe dare
Ma ai giapponesi
Non gli frega mica niente
Invece
Non sta violando
Una legge giapponese
Tanto che quando
Anni dopo
Per anticipare
La fine
Verrà arrestato
Non sarà neanche
Ben chiaro
Su che base
Processarlo
In realtà
Ha violato
Un'unica legge
Proprio in quegli anni
In Giappone
E' uscita una nuova legge
Che punisce
Con la morte
Chiunque comunichi
Informazioni
A un paese
Comunista
E su questa base
Sarà poi possibile
I magistrati giapponesi
Condannare Sorge
Il quale invece
Si limita
A raccogliere
Informazioni
Le informazioni
Si possono mandare
Via microfilm
Per corriere
Si manda un corriere
A Shanghai
Come al solito
Dove ci sono
Occidentali
Che vanno e vengono
Grandi alberghi
Per incontrarsi
E anche lì
Gli incontri
Nei grandi alberghi
Naturalmente avvengono
Con modalità
Da romanzo
Andrai il giorno tale
Al bar
Dell'hotel imperial
Dove
Dovrai avere
Un libro giallo
E metterlo
A destra
Sul tavolino
Vedrai
Un'altra persona
Che ha un libro
Di colore verde
Posato a sinistro
Sul tavolino
Vi guarderete
Non direte niente
Quella sera
Vi troverete
Nella tal via
Ecco funziona
Tutto così
Non è che lo puoi fare
Tutti i giorni
Di mandare
I microfilm
A Shanghai
E Mosca invece
Vuole essere
Tenuta informata
La situazione
Sta cambiando
Nel mondo
La guerra
È sempre più vicina
Mosca è disperatamente
Affamata
Di informazioni
Perciò
Perciò ci vuole
La radio
E la radio
Vuol dire
Che ci vuole
Un tecnico europeo
L'unica persona
Che sorge
Si è portato dietro
Poi lo farà sostituire
Con un altro
Più bravo
E che sarà
Appunto
Un membro cruciale
Della rete
È il tecnico radio
Tenete conto
Che la radio
È ancora abbastanza
Gli inizi
Non è una tecnologia
Così padroneggiata
Da tutti
E qui ci vuole invece
Un mago
Il mago
Lo trovano
E anche lui
Viene reclutato
Con modalità
Da romanzo
È un altro tedesco
Che si chiama
Max Clausen
È un tedesco
Di Hamburgo
La città più rossa
Della Germania
È stato
Radiotelegrafista
Nell'esercito imperiale
Durante la guerra
Poi si è imbarcato
È uno di Hamburgo
Si è imbarcato
Sui pescherecci
Come radiotelefonista
E lì
Sul peschereccio
Un agente segreto
Sovietico
Lo contatta
E gli chiede
Se è sempre comunista
E se è disposta
A lavorare
Per il comunismo
Max Clausen
Dice di sì
Allora gli danno
Un biglietto
Di prima classe
Per Mosca
E un romanzo
Di Thomas Mann
E gli dicono
Dentro
Il romanzo
Troverai
La tua destinazione
Dentro il romanzo
Ci sono delle sottolineature
Che formano
Un messaggio
In codice
Un codice
Abbastanza facile
Evidentemente
Si sono detti
Se non riesce
A decifrarlo
Non ci serve
È inutile
Se ci riesce
Arrivato a Mosca
Vedrà l'indirizzo
A cui deve presentarsi
Max Clausen
In treno
Prima classe
Decifra
Il messaggio
Arriva a Mosca
Ha un indirizzo
Si presenta
E viene assunto
Gli fanno fare
Un corso
Da radiotelegrafista
Di altissimo livello
Diventa appunto
Un mago
Quando lo mandano
A Tokyo
Perché Sorge
Si è stufato
Del radiotelegrafista
Che aveva
Troppa paura
Non trasmetteva mai
E ne vuole un altro
Max Clausen
Si imbarca
Con la moglie
Per le spie
Fa fino portarsi
Dietro la moglie
Provoca meno sospetti
I membri europei
Del gruppo di Sorge
Hanno tutti la moglie
Max Clausen
Si imbarca
Per Tokyo
In valigia
Ha in tutto
E per tutto
Come equipaggiamento
Tecnico
Due valvoline
Sono il modello
Delle altre
Che deve procurarsi
Tutte le altre valvole
E tutti gli altri
Elementi
Per costruire la radio
Se li compra
A Tokyo
Non nei negozi
Di radio
Perché rischierebbe
Di provocare sospetti
Nei negozi
Di lampadine
Ci mette tre mesi
Per procurarsi
Tutte le
Lavorano sul lungo periodo
Come vedete
I servizi segreti sovietici
In tre mesi
Si procura tutte le componenti
Costruisce
Una trasmittente
Smontabile
Che è in grado
Di smontare
In cinque minuti
E rimontare in dieci
Che si porta dietro
In una borsetta
Per cui può trasmettere
Da punti diversi
Della città
Da case diverse
Di agenti
Senza essere mai
Intercettato
Naturalmente anche lui
Ha bisogno di una copertura
E lui è un operaio
Allora gli inventano
Un'azienda
Max Clausen
Si trasferisce a Tokyo
Come piccolo industriale
E apre una ditta
Che fabbrica qualcosa
Che neanche io ho capito bene
Cos'è
Ma insomma
Macchine specializzate
Per fotografare
Disegni industriali
Comunque
La copertura ufficiale
È questa ditta
Che prospera
La ditta
Fa un sacco di soldi
Alla fine
Avrà 14 dipendenti
E questo è un guaio
Perché verso la fine
Max Clausen
Che da operaio
È diventato padroncino
E sta facendo i soldi
Comincia a avere
Meno tempo
Per fare la spia
E comincia a trovare
Che fare l'industriale
Di successo
È molto più interessante
Per cui negli ultimi tempi
Oscilla un po'
Anche se fino alla fine
Andrà avanti
E poi Mosca
A un certo punto
Fa un errore drammatico
Siccome i soldi sono pochi
A un certo punto
Da Mosca dicono
Beh
Visto che Clausen
Sta facendo così tanti soldi
Con l'azienda
Usate i suoi soldi
E lui ci rimane male
È proprio l'esempio classico
Del proletario
Che è diventato appunto
Padrone
Adesso insomma
Però comunque
Per il resto
Va alla grande
È un radiotelegrafista
Espertissimo
E lui è in grado
Di trasmettere
All'Unione Sovietica
Da dove negli ultimi anni
Quando il mondo
Sta veramente precipitando
Verso la guerra
Dall'estate del 38
Da Mosca
Gli fanno sapere
Guardate voi
Trasmettete quando volete
Nel primo quarto d'ora
Di ogni ora
24 ore su 24
Ci sarà qualcuno
Sintonizzato
Sulla vostra frequenza
Per sentire
Se avete qualcosa
Da trasmettere
E intanto
Il dottor Sorge
Fa la bella vita
A Tokyo
Perché è una persona
Simpatica e di compagnia
Lo conoscono tutti
Vive alla giapponese
Ha preso in affitto
Una casetta
Alla giapponese
Col giardino
Con una governante
Giapponese
Che gli prepara
Da mangiare
In casa si mette
Il kimono
Dorme sul tatami
La casa
La riempita di libri
Quelli che riesce
In un modo
Nell'altro
A procurarsi
Sul Giappone
Storia del Giappone
Economia
Alla fine
Quando lo arrestano
Li trovano in casa
Più di mille libri
Sul Giappone
Fa il bagno
Tutti i giorni
Nella tinozza
Di legno
All'usanza
Giapponese
I suoi amici
Dell'ambasciata tedesca
Sono un po' stupiti
Perché questa cosa
Di fare il bagno
Tutti i giorni
Tra gli europei
Dell'epoca
Non è assolutamente
Venuta in mente
A nessuno
Ma lui vive
Alla giapponese
Di giorno
Di notte
Esce
E va a bere
Con gli amici tedeschi
E' un grandioso bevitore
Il dottor Sorge
E Tokyo
E' una città straordinaria
Dove appunto
Dominano la xenofobia
E la polizia segreta
Però è piena
Di locali occidentali
Ci sono ristoranti
Per stranieri
Dove le cameriere
Giapponesi
Si tingono
I capelli di biondo
O di arancione
Fino a quando
La polizia segreta
Non proibisce
La pratica
Antipatriottica
Ci sono birrerie tedesche
Con nomi come
L'oro del Reno
Dove Sorge
Spesso viene visto
Ubriaco
Fradicio
In piena notte
Con i suoi amici
Dell'ambasciata tedesca
Ci sono i ristoranti
Giapponesi di lusso
Con le geisce
Quelli meno di lusso
Con le ragazze
Più facili
Sorge passa le notti fuori
Si ubriaca
Va a letto con le ragazze
E a un certo punto
Se ne trova una fissa
Si chiama Hanako
E cameriera
Per l'appunto
All'oro del Reno
Diventa la sua amante
E a questo punto
Lui la tira fuori
Dal ristorante
Le chiede cosa vuole fare
Di bello
E lui dice
Io vorrei studiare lingue
E lui le paga
Gli studi di lingue
Hanako
È una che è rimasta fedele
A Sorge
E non sapeva niente
Della sua vera identità
È rimasta fedele a lui
Sempre
Poi nel dopoguerra
Racconterà spesso di lui
Dice
Hanako
Sapevo benissimo
Che non era innamorato
Di me
Però era tanto gentile
E lei era innamorata
Persa invece
In tutto questo
C'è un problema
Bere tanto
Ha anche dei rischi
Il dottor Sorge
Beve veramente tanto
E quando beve
Fa chiasso
E diventa anche brutale
Tanto che le padrone
Di casa
Della comunità europea
Frase che in questo momento
Mi rendo conto
Che suona male
Della piccola comunità
Degli europei
Che vivono a Tokyo
Ecco
Del dottor Sorge
Cominciano a diffidare un po'
È tanto amico
Dei loro mariti
Però invitarlo a cena
Smettono
Perché quando beve
Diventa sgradevole
Ed è perfino strano
Che un uomo
Di quel calibro
Abbia questa debolezza
Solo che evidentemente
La tensione
Della sua doppia identità
Era tale
Che in qualche modo
In qualche modo
La devi scaricare
E lui la scaricava bevendo
C'è una donna
Che l'aveva conosciuto
A Berlino da ragazzo
E che lo incontra di nuovo
Negli anni trenta
A Tokyo
E dice
Lo avevo conosciuto
Come uno studente
Romantico
E idealista
Ma era diventato
Un uomo violento
Un forte bevitore
Era ancora
Un gran bell'uomo
Ma gli zigomi
E la bocca
Si erano incavati
Il naso
Si era appuntito
Era completamente cambiato
Di lì a poco
Cambia ancora di più
Perché un'altra passione
Del dottor Sorge
Sono le corse pazze
In motocicletta
Ha comprato una moto
Da Max Krausen
E di notte
Dopo aver bevuto
Gira all'impazzata
Per le strade di Tokyo
Una notte
Va a schiantarsi
Dopo essersi ubriacato
Fradicio
Contro un muro
Dell'ambasciata americana
A Tokyo
Ci sono i poliziotti
Giapponesi
Arrivano
Lui fa appena in tempo
A chiedere
Che chiami
Nel suo amico
Max Krausen
Lo porta in ospedale
Arriva Max Krausen
Esorge
Fa in tempo
A dargli le chiavi
Di casa
Perché è un cittadino
Tedesco importante
L'ambasciata
Andrà a chiudere casa
E allora Krausen
Deve arrivare
Prima di quelli
Dell'ambasciata
E pulire casa
Che non ci siano
Documenti
Compromettenti
Fa appena in tempo
A dargli le chiavi
Poi sviene
Quando poi si risveglia
In ospedale
Ha la macella fratturata
Ha perso
Una parte dei denti
Un conoscente
Dice che dopo
Che esce dall'ospedale
Le cicatrici
Sul viso
Lo facevano
Rassomigliare
A una maschera
Teatrale
Giapponese
E davano
Al suo viso
Un'espressione
Quasi demoniaca
Ora
Finora
Non sono entrato
Nel dettaglio
Delle informazioni
Che Sorge
E i suoi
Hanno fornito
A Mosca
In quegli anni
Ma ve l'ho detto
Se c'è una rete di spie
Che ha influenzato
Il corso
Della seconda guerra mondiale
E quella di Sorge
Quando lui è andato lì
Il grande problema
Per l'Unione Sovietica
È avere informazioni
Sul Giappone
Sulla politica giapponese
Però mentre Sorge
È lì
Nasce l'alleanza
Fra Germania
E Giappone
Ed è un'alleanza
Decisamente orientata
Contro l'Unione Sovietica
Tanto che si chiamerà
Il patto
Anticomintern
Questa alleanza
Fra Germania e Giappone
Viene negoziata
In totale segreto
Tanto che
Da parte tedesca
Perfino il ministero
Degli esteri
Non è informato
Negozia personalmente
Il ministro degli esteri
Von Ribbentrop
Il suo ministero
Non sa niente
Nemmeno l'ambasciata tedesca
A Tokyo
Sa niente
Di questo negoziato
Per creare
La nuova alleanza
Fra Germania e Giappone
A un certo punto
L'ambasciatore
Ott
Assentore
Di qualche cosa
Di questo negoziato
E decide
Di scrivere
A Berlino
Dicendomi
Fate la cortesia
Di spiegare anche a me
Che sono l'ambasciatore
A Tokyo
Se davvero
Stiamo facendo
L'alleanza
Con il Giappone
Però è una cosa
Troppo grossa
È troppo eccitato
L'ambasciatore Ott
Deve raccontarla
A qualcuno
Quindi
La racconta
Al suo caro amico
Il dottor Sorge
E si fa aiutare
Da lui
A cifrare
Il dispaccio
A Berlino
Per chiedere
Informazioni
Su questi negoziati
Berlino risponde
E in buona sostanza
Mosca
Viene a sapere
Di questi negoziati
Quasi prima
Del ministero degli esteri
Tedesco
E questo è uno
Poi
A Mosca
Interessa sapere
Cosa vuol fare
L'armata del Quantung
Il Giappone
Politicamente
Militarmente
Si deve espandere
Perché se no
Soffoca
Ma in che direzione
A nord
Contro di noi
Oppure contro la Cina
Oppure contro l'America
Nel Pacifico
Contro le colonie
Inglesi e francesi
Non lo sanno neanche
I giapponesi
Perché ci sono fazioni diverse
L'armata del Quantung
Preme per l'attacco a nord
Contro l'Unione Sovietica
Giusto in quel momento
Come vi dicevo
L'amico Ozaki
Diventa consulente
Delle ferrovie
Della Manciuria
Meridionale
E quindi
È informato direttamente
Di tutto quello
Che vuole fare
L'armata del Quantung
È in grado
Di mettere le mani
Su documenti segreti
Da cui risulta
Tutto quello
Che l'armata del Quantung
Sa
Sulle truppe sovietiche
In Siberia
E in Mongolia
L'armata del Quantung
A un certo punto
Decide di provarci
Sono convinti
Che i sovietici
Siano deboli
Che i giapponesi
Se provano a invadere
La Mongolia
Che è un paese
Indipendente
Ma comunista
E protetto dai sovietici
Passeranno
Come nel burro
Hanno informazioni precise
I giapponesi
Sulle forze sovietiche
In quella zona
Quello che non sanno
È che Sorge
Ha informato Mosca
Che loro lo sanno
E di conseguenza
A Mosca
Hanno avuto modo
Di cambiare completamente
Lo schieramento
Delle loro forze
In quella zona
Sorge è anche riuscito
Tramite i suoi agenti giapponesi
A mandare l'organigramma
Completo
Dell'armata del Quantung
Risultato
Nell'estate del 39
L'armata del Quantung
Decide di fare un esperimento
È una di quelle cose
Che fanno
Senza neanche informare
Il governo giapponese
Glielo dicono dopo
Sconfinano in Mongolia
Ma non quattro gatti
Sconfina un'armata
In Mongolia
Diverse divisioni
E avanzano in Mongolia
A questo punto scoppia
Una vera e propria guerra segreta
Non dichiarata
Che tutti sono d'accordo
Di non comunicare al mondo
Per cui nessuno verrà a sapere niente
Siamo nell'agosto del 39
Il mondo ha ben altro a cui pensare
Sta scoppiando
Hitler sta per invadere la Polonia
In Mongolia
I giapponesi avanzano
E davanti a loro
Le forze sovietiche
Sono perfettamente informate di tutto
Grazie ai rapporti di Sorge
Al comando delle forze sovietiche
C'è un generale
Che diventerà famoso
Sei anni dopo
Perché entrerà a Berlino
Si chiama Zhukov
In quel momento
Non è ancora famoso
E anzi
Quello che fa in quel momento
Non lo saprà nessuno
Perché il mondo
Non lo deve sapere
Di questa piccola guerra
In questa piccola guerra
Il generale Zhukov
Affronta le forze giapponesi
Entrate in Mongolia
Le circonda
Le annienta
A questo punto
L'armata del Quantung
Decide che forse
Non è il caso
Di fare la guerra
Contra l'Unione Sovietica
Tutto sommato
È meglio invadere la Cina
O fare altre cose
E due
Ma se il Giappone
Si è rotto i denti
E non ha più intenzione
Di attaccare l'Unione Sovietica
Hitler si che ha intenzione
Di farlo
E lo fa
Nel giugno del 41
Sorge
Ha avvertito Mosca
Almeno un mese prima
Questa è la cosa
Più controversa
Dell'intero servizio
Che Sorge ha reso
All'Unione Sovietica
Perché si sa
Che Stalin
Che è stato informato
Non solo da lui
Ma anche tramite altri canali
Che i nazisti
Volevano invadere
Perché c'erano militari
Tedeschi
Comunisti
Che scappavano
Attraversavano il confine
Per avvertire
Che l'operazione Barbarossa
Stava per scattare
Stalin era talmente
Terrorizzato
Da questa guerra
Per cui sapeva
Di non essere pronto
Che non ha voluto crederci
Ed è questa appunto
Forse l'informazione
Di Sorge
Che avrebbe potuto essere
Vitale
E che non è stata creduta
Tanto che
Quando scatta
L'operazione Barbarossa
Come sapete
I tedeschi all'inizio
Sfondano
Hanako
L'amante di Sorge
Ha raccontato
Dopo la guerra
Che un'unica volta
Lo ha visto piangere
Il giorno in cui
La Germania
Attaccò davvero
L'Unione Sovietica
E allora
Lei gli chiese
Perché era così sconvolto
E Sorge rispose
Perché sono solo
Però non è ancora finita
Perché adesso
Che la Germania
Sta avanzando
Nell'Unione Sovietica
Come nel burro
Diretta a Mosca
È particolarmente
Vitale
Sapere
Se i giapponesi
Non ci hanno ripensato
E non intendono
Attaccare anche loro
Dalla Siberia
In Giappone
Si discute furiosamente
La Marina
Vorrebbe attaccare
A sud
Vuole attaccare
La flotta americana
Per l'Arbor
Attaccare le colonie
Inglesi e francesi
In Indocina
L'esercito
Vuole continuare
L'invasione della Cina
L'armata del Quantung
Vorrebbe attaccare
L'Unione Sovietica
Ma si è rotta i denti
Prima
E non ha più
Tanta influenza politica
Per quei
In quei mesi
Dell'estate
Autunno del 41
Nei circoli governativi
Giapponesi
Si discute furiosamente
E in quei circoli
Governativi
Si muove un uomo
Che conosce tutti
Il suo parere
Lo chiedono tutti
E Ozaki
Il quale poi
Riferisce a Sorge
Tutto quello che sente
E Sorge
È in grado
Di riferire a Mosca
Che alla fine
Il Giappone
Ha deciso
Attaccheranno a sud
Nel Pacifico
Attaccheranno
Per l'Arbor
La Siberia
È al sicuro
E Stalin
Può ritirare
Le truppe
Dall'estremo Oriente
E trasferirle
A Occidente
Appena in tempo
Per fermare i tedeschi
Davanti a Mosca
Nel dicembre del 41
E qui in realtà
C'è anche qualcosa di più
Perché in realtà
I magistrati
Che poco dopo
Ci stiamo arrivando
Abbiamo finito
Praticamente
I magistrati
Che interrogeranno
Sorge e Ozaki
Di lì a poco
Si accorgeranno
Che loro
Non hanno soltanto
Mandato informazioni
A Mosca
Ozaki
Era un uomo
Influente
Consigliere del governo
E Ozaki
Ha contribuito
A far prendere
Quella decisione
A tutte le discussioni
Riservatissime
A cui partecipava
Ozaki insisteva
Attaccare l'Unione Sovietica
È pericoloso
Non conviene
Molto meglio
Attaccare gli americani
I magistrati
Giapponesi
Che li interrogano
Dopo averli arrestati
Rimangono sconvolti
E
Hanno quasi l'impressione
Che la guerra del Giappone
Contro l'America
Sia stata
Come dire
Non dico provocata
Ma insomma
Questi maledetti comunisti
Hanno aiutato
A far andare le cose
In quel modo
E i magistrati giapponesi
Si rizzano i capelli in testa
All'idea di cosa direbbe
Il paese
Se sapesse
Che questa guerra mortale
In cui ci siamo impegnati
Bene
I comunisti
Ci hanno menati
Per il naso
E ci hanno indotti
A fare quello
Che volevano loro
Tanto che i magistrati
Giapponesi
Lo dicono poi
Nel dopoguerra
Gli americani
Noi abbiamo rinunciato
A approfondire
Questo aspetto
Perché avevamo paura
Che nel paese
Scoppiasse la rivoluzione
Se si veniva a sapere
Ecco a questo punto
Sorge
Ha la netta sensazione
Di aver finito
I nazisti
Stanno invadendo
Unione Sovietica
Non c'è ancora stato
L'attacco giapponese
Per l'arbor
Ma ormai
È deciso
E il 15 ottobre
Del 41
Sorge
Trasmette un messaggio
A Mosca
Chiedendo
Se non pensano
Che sarebbe più utile
Che lui
E Max Clausen
Adesso fossero trasferiti
In un altro paese
Magari in Germania
Sono tedeschi
Tutti e due
Lì potrebbero essere
Molto utili
Quello stesso giorno
Viene arrestato
Ozaki
Tre giorni dopo
Viene arrestato
Sorge
Clausen
E tutti gli altri
La rete di Sorge
È caduta quasi per caso
O meglio
Era così estesa
Che prima o poi
Un filo
I giapponesi
Lo avrebbero trovato
Ma lo trovano per caso
E ci mettono
Un sacco di tempo
A seguirlo
Due anni prima
Nel novembre del 39
La gestapo giapponese
La Tocco
Aveva arrestato
Un membro
Del partito comunista
Clandestino
Arrestato
Torturato
Deve fare dei nomi
Altri nomi
Di comunisti
E questo fa un nome
Di una donna
Una certa signora
Kitabayashi
La quale era
Un'emigrata in America
Era vissuta a Los Angeles
Poi è tornata in Giappone
E lei è comunista
La Tocco
Mette sotto sorveglianza
Questa vecchia signora
Ormai è un'anziana signora
Lei è il marito
Una coppia anziana
Li sorvegliano
Per due anni
Sperando che capiti
Chissà cosa
Non prendono niente
Dopo due anni
Si stufano
Li arrestano
Siamo appunto
Nell'autunno del 41
La signora Kitabayashi
Arrestata
Le dicono
Adesso devi fare
Dei nomi di comunisti
E lei cerca di ricordarsi
Dice sì
Quando ero in California
C'era un giapponese comunista
Che conoscevo
Si chiamava Miyagi
La polizia segreta giapponese
Questo Miyagi
Non l'ha mai sentito nominare
Vanno a prenderlo
Miyagi
Era il primo giapponese
Che Sorge
Aveva reclutato
Nella sua rete
Lo vanno a prendere
Lo portano alla polizia
Mentre lo torturano
Si butta da una finestra
Del commissariato di polizia
Cose che succedono
In tutti i paesi
Come vedete
Non riesce ad ammazzarsi
Si rompe una gamba
Lo vanno a riprendere
Lo riportano su
Il giorno dopo
Comincia a fare i nomi
Denuncia Sorge
Denuncia Ozaki
Denuncia Max Clausen
Forse anche senza questo
Sorge non sarebbe durato
Così a lungo
Perché in realtà
È venuto fuori
Dagli archivi di Berlino
Che nel 1940
Il partito nazista
Bontà sua
Riscavando
Fra le vecchie scartoffie
Aveva ritrovato
Qualche informazione
Sul fatto che Sorge
Era un comunista
Da giovane
E si erano
Un po' insospettiti
Però la Gestapo
Schellenberg
Comandante della Gestapo
Aveva preso informazioni
E questo Sorge
Era veramente
Un uomo così prezioso
Un nazista fedele
Amicissimo
Del nostro ambasciatore
Che dice che
Quest'uomo
Gli serve moltissimo
Insomma
Schellenberg
Capo della Gestapo
Aveva detto
No vabbè
Questo Sorge
Lasciatelo stare
Insomma
Aveva solo detto
All'ambasciatore Ott
La Gestapo
Senza compromettersi
E senza fare nomi
Tieni d'occhio
Però
La gente che ha intorno
Mi raccomando
L'ambasciatore Ott
Si era preoccupato
Che ci sia una talpa
All'ambasciata
Non l'aveva detto
A nessuno
Tranne al suo migliore amico
Il dottor Sorge
I tedeschi
Si fidavano di Sorge
Talmente tanto
Che quando la polizia
Segreta giapponese
Va ad arrestarlo
La prima cosa che succede
E che l'ambasciata tedesca
Protesta
Protesta ufficialmente
Contro l'arresto
Di un illustre membro
Della comunità tedesca
A Tokyo
E
L'ambasciatore Ott
Va a trovarlo in prigione
E per parecchio tempo
L'ambasciata tedesca
Fa pressioni sui giapponesi
Perché Sorge
Si è rilasciato
Deve essere un errore
Sicuramente
Quanto all'opinione pubblica
Giapponese
Da quel poco
Che viene a sapere
Dai giornali
Si convince
Che Sorge
E' stato arrestato
In quanto spia tedesca
Perché
Anche fra alleati
Ovviamente ci si spia
Insomma
I tedeschi si fidavano
Totalmente
Come disse Sorge
A suo tempo
Credo di menarli tutti
Per il naso
Quando poi
La verità vera
Verrà fuori
A Berlino
Il capo della Gestapo
Schellenberg
Sarà convocato
Dal suo superiore
Heinrich Himmler
Con cui avrà
Disse lui
Un colloquio
Molto spiacevole
Sorge e Ozaki
Vengono arrestati
E processati
Un processo lunghissimo
Meticoloso
Che dura anni
Durante il quale
Scrivono moltissimi
Memoriali
Per spiegare
La loro posizione
Tutto materiale
Che esiste
Ed è stato studiato
E' una vicenda
Anch'essa
A suo modo
Straordinaria
Un interrogativo
Che subito ci si è posti
Ovviamente
Ma li hanno torturati
Non è facile rispondere
Perché il Giappone
Era uno stranissimo
Paese
La polizia militare
La Kenpei Tai
Si sapeva
Che torturava
Selvaggiamente
La Gestapo
Giapponese
La toccò
Torturava
Ma con più attenzione
Gli stranieri
Di riguardo
Magari no
La magistratura
Questa è la cosa
Pazzesca
Era indipendente
Serissima
Faceva rispettare
Le leggi
E la magistratura
Giapponese
Per tre anni
Ha interrogato
Sorge e Ozaki
Con estrema gentilezza
E estrema attenzione
Verbalizzando
Tutte le loro
Dichiarazioni
Con un grande
Formalismo
Sembra probabile
Che non siano stati
Torturati
I loro due
Altri dei loro agenti
Forse sì
Se dobbiamo basarci
Sul fatto che
Molti sono morti
In carcere
Hanako
L'amante di Sorge
Va a trovare
La polizia
Decide subito
Che effettivamente
Lei non capisce
Niente di politica
Probabilmente
Il maschilismo
Giapponese
Qui aiuta
E quindi
Lei poveretta
Non c'entra niente
La lasciano in pace
Sorge rimane dunque
In prigione
Per anni
Durante i quali
Ha dei colloqui
All'inizio
Con l'ambasciatore
Ott
Che poi però
Suppongo
Non si è più
Andato a trovarlo
Con Hanako
Che va a trovarlo
Regolarmente
Riceve giornali
E in grado
Di seguire
L'andamento
Della guerra
L'uomo
Che aveva pianto
Il giorno
Dell'attacco tedesco
All'unione sovietica
A un certo punto
Viene informato
Della resa
Dell'armata
Di Paulus
A Stalingrado
E quel giorno
Fu visto
Che ballava
Di gioia
Nella cella
Alla fine
Dopo tre anni
I magistrati
I procuratori
Un intero staff
Di procuratori
Che li hanno interrogati
Arrivano a processo
E a sentenza
Sorge
E Ozaki
Sono condannati
A morte
Soltanto loro
Tutti gli altri
Sono condannati
A lunghe pene
Detentive
Ma pochi mesi dopo
Gli americani
Entrano a Tokyo
E aprono le porte
Delle prigioni
Chi è ancora vivo
Esce
Max Clausen
Per esempio
Esce
Bisogna dire
Che Max Clausen
Se l'era cavata
Anche perché
Unico
Aveva rilasciato
Al procuratore giapponese
Una dichiarazione
In cui diceva
Che lui era venuto
In Giappone
Pensando che fosse
Un paese nemico
Dei lavoratori
Ma si era sbagliato
Il Giappone
Ha il governo
Più sincero
E amico del popolo
Che lui abbia mai conosciuto
Queste cose
I giapponesi piacciono
Max Clausen
Non viene condannato a morte
Gli americani
Lo fanno uscire
E se n'è poi andato
Con la moglie
A vivere
In Germania Est
Invece
Sorge
E Ozaki
Erano stati impiccati
Il 7 novembre
Di tutti e due
I procuratori
Che li avevano interrogati
Per mesi
Per anni
Hanno lasciato
Una testimonianza
Estremamente rispettosa
I funzionari
Del Toko
Che avevano interrogato
Per cinque mesi
Ozaki
Scrissero nel loro rapporto
Che lui aveva accettato
Di collaborare
Con Sorge
Perché lo considerava
Un incarico
Onorevole
E il Giappone
È uno strano paese
Da noi
Uno che fa
Una vicenda di questo genere
Sarebbe considerato
Un traditore
E abborrito
Invece
I giapponesi
Ammirano quelli che muoiono
Per le loro idee
Ozaki
È un personaggio
Famoso in Giappone
E nel dopoguerra
Era quasi una specie
Di eroe nazionale
Subito dopo la guerra
Sua moglie
Pubblicò un libro
Con le lettere d'amore
Che Ozaki
Le aveva scritto
Dal carcere
Il titolo è
L'amore
Come una stella cadente
E questo libro
È rimasto in Giappone
Un best seller
Per anni
Quanto a Richard Sorge
Icca
Per gli amici
Continuò fino all'ultimo
A essere l'uomo
Che piaceva a tutti
Il procuratore Yoshikawa
Che aveva condotto
Il suo interrogatorio
Dichiarò
In tutta la mia vita
Non ho mai incontrato
Un uomo
Di tale levatura
Grazie
Grazie mille
A domani
Per chi ci sarà
Grazie mille